okay hello everyone we are about to do a
design review for version 13.1 feature
of awesome language to do with astronomy
and where we start in
yes so the main player here is
astroposition so i would recommend we
open that page
okay
and the code is in the x kernel okay
i'm running the x code
okay
now we haven't looked at this at all
before is that correct
very briefly i think on monday perhaps
or a few no last week very briefly
okay
so the key so this object of course is
modeled completely on geoposition
and
my
way of looking at it is that it has
three arguments the first is just
numbers
the second is the physics of the problem
the third is the maths of the problem so
the physics is like the datum in geo
or the time system in dates while the
maths is like the projection in geo or
the calendar in dates
yes you know the physics you can express
it in many
equivalent mathematical ways
okay but an astroposition is actually an
event in space time
yes it's it's an event referred to a
frame which is the second argument
and then you have the freedom of
expressing the spatial coordinates in
different ways and that's the third
argument but the t if the t is omitted
it is a thing for all time is that
correct
effectively yes even though technically
it's now
the code will
if it doesn't specify a t
it is it will assume now whatever now
means and that's not the case
yes
it's it's the now of the frame
which is in the second argument and by
default in the same way that in geo we
have this it
rf
2000
here we have the icrs
which is the main coordinate reference
system now used in astronomy since like
one decade ago
and this this is the international
celestial reference system which is for
the first time a reference system that
doesn't move in space
it's a completely new idea in astronomy
however you mean it doesn't move in
space how can something not i mean i
don't understand what about the
expansion of the universe and things
like that
so what they do is that they they take
like
several hundred quasars very far away
equations they are so far that we cannot
see them moving
and so they give these quasars
coordinates are consistent
with the whole thing not being moving
to to microarch seconds precision or
close to microsoft as opposed to the i
mean those quasars are redshifted but
that is a a parallel movement but the
direction vector is constant exactly
exactly
so so these this icrs
is the best we can do to have something
non-rotated non-rotating in space before
this all the frames we were using were
associated to the rotation of the earth
to the ecliptic
to things like that and all these planes
were always moving nice
okay
and this is i hope we have the quasars
in the in our database
the reference quasars
um no we do we don't have quasar data
and uh all the galaxies that we have are
relatively nearby i honestly don't know
what the reference quasi quasars are be
interesting to to know if that's uh been
disclosed
better been described i mean absolutely
yeah
yeah i think we can get i'm not sure if
that would be its own domain or if it
would be part of galaxy data quasars
technically are galaxies but i think we
should have them but separate
uh okay i have to find a good database
for quizzers
okay um
there is one final technical thing
before we start looking at anything else
which is the difference between icrs and
bcrs and this is quite interesting icrs
is like the asymptotic version it's the
direction
yes the ecrs is a fully relativistic
coordinate system something that can
define that can attach
a a
tuple of four numbers to every point in
space time
and bcrs b is stands for body centric
the solar system by center so the the
center is the solar system by the center
and then it's it's one of these
frames or coordinate systems that has
everything being space-like
so it can assign
simultaneity
these
okay hold on everything is space like as
in
so
i don't understand that quite so that
you're saying mars now
go ahead explain
so so imagine that we are at the very
center of the solar system and we have a
clock there yep now with that clock we
can define we can send light rays going
there and coming back
so with that trick we can define some
sort of
space like surfaces which we are going
to declare all points of those hyper
surfaces have the same time
right
yes i'm just trying to understand that
all
okay but we we've got the light going
so in astronomy we always have this
question of do we use light combs and so
when we say i'm observing
something i'm referring to the time of
my observation so that the light rate
was emitted many many years ago yes
or we have found a way of constructing
hypersurfaces
yeah i understand what are the
crisscrossing of photons like what is
the
some
ladder construction things like that
where you can crisscross things to get
something which is the simultaneous
space-like surface exactly yes
so this bcrs is the fundamental
coordinate system which is constructed
that way it's it's it's a
it's a way of assigning
four
numbers to every point in space-time and
you can refer to now as a space-like
surface
okay
okay so when you when you say now
that's
i see i see that's based like a service
but you don't know what happened
in the now in the elsewhere now until a
light cone time has passed
so by now we we are referring
essentially to the hypersurface of this
bcra system
that that is crossing us right now
are we going to need some light cone
functions that answer questions like
given that you are at this point in the
bcrs frame
what is the time delay from that point
right yes
um so this is handle
further down so all these frames have
parameters and
and by default
yeah go ahead exactly light time light
time will have three values geometric
which is what we just described i'm
using now in a in a in a space like
cyber surface it will be
advanced or [ __ ]
and so
with this we are saying i'm referring to
the observation time so i'm i'm saying
where mars was
before because i'm i'm i'm giving the
observation time of the light rate
arriving at me
not
where
mars is right now in the pcrs
yep
exactly so we control it with that
parameter
right
this is the sort of thing that might
deserve a different symbol but because
the changes are so small it's not like
when we change from your position to
geogrid position in which the numbers
are totally different
a subtlety right now yeah yeah yes but
but very important for us for
observations of course what on earth is
the wavelength thing
yes so
oh god this business oh no
exactly we are observing from the earth
lights light rates go through atmosphere
and they change a lot
so we have to model the atmosphere oh oh
god that's what's the way we have
this is an effective astral position so
i'm so confused so this astro position
is based on an observation on the earth
or somewhere else like it could be the
solar system
right right so i mean normally if you're
using the icrs frame
then
i don't understand how okay
in your in your physics and mathematics
characterization where does the
um
um
uh you know
where does the business about aberration
in the atmosphere and so on come in
okay so if we are looking from the solar
system by center there is not much fear
to worry about so the bcrs does not have
those parameters
okay however if we are looking
from the frame that we call horizon
then we are we have to give a location
on earth or some somebody else or
somewhere else and then we have to
provide those parameters
well hold on so
we really want to call it horizon
it's it's typically called horizontal
and for example we have now already
celestial system goes to horizon to
refer to that frame
in in functions like
uh some position
so that's why i'm i'm imitating that but
we could use some other name okay but
but it's it's super confusing i mean in
other words the question of whether the
thing has an atmosphere
are we i mean like if you say jupiter
for example and if you're on jupiter and
you give a geolocation on jupiter
whatever the heck that means
let's say mars for example because it
has a surface so we can refer to a
yeah okay fine
okay
so do we have enough of a model for the
martian atmosphere that we can do this
um
no
no
at the moment the values are earth
values but that's why we provide the
parameters so that you can specify your
own values
i see
my plan was to effectively
remove these unless you are on
earth if you are on earth we use
standard values though you can
modify them
i'm not planning to consult in real time
what's the temperature of this location
things like that
we just have standard values yeah yeah i
understand
although you could say air temperature
colon greater than air temperature of
wherever
sorry how do you think of that well i
mean you're allowing you to specify
the air temperature so when you make the
call to astral position you could
retrieve the air temperature for that
particular location at that time
right
we could but it's going to make the
whole thing very slow no i understand
that but i'm not suggesting i mean you
know you could cache it right you could
say air temperature you know you could
say with air temperature equals blah
blah blah blah and then feed it into
each other okay let's talk about other
planets for a second okay
so
it seems to me you know
the case of most interest since
currently 100
of our users
live on this planet
or you know that is their permanent
homes on this planet
um
it seems like we can treat that as
special so to speak and especially since
we have much more data about it
and it seems like to be able to say i
mean so sun position
if you say sun position and you have a
model
can you do that where sun position is
referring to mars
does that work right now no
okay so sun position is specifically for
the earth
correct
although we could make it work for mars
we have enough data to make it work for
mars
right possibly with this new stuff um it
hasn't been factored in yet but
all right fine but so so i'm trying to
understand
so
i kind of feel like
let's see
so some position takes at your location
we could have a geolocation comma
jupiter or common mars
yeah
but geolocation is normally
oh it takes a natural geolocation as an
argument right a deposition yes
right so if i say geoposition 0 0 geo
model error moon
it's a second argument with don't even
need the option
just an entity
yeah or a string
something could work something like that
could work it doesn't run out but right
i think that'd be nice to have that work
i mean i don't think it's beyond our
capabilities to figure out how to make
that work
um
we would have to be careful with which
frame we are referring to
because some position right now uses
earth-based
frames
so i mean it would be also it would
require also generalization of the
celestial system
no but but the horizon frame here
is at a given geo location where the
geolocation is of whatever planet we're
talking about right
yes but even that would require some
orientation of
of the horizon and things like that
i see the question is which way is north
exactly or
i mean is the planet processing we have
precision precision models for the earth
but we would need to consult precision
models for mars to convert
oh boy but at least at the very least
other than the which way is north which
affects the the um right ascension
the
that
or affects the um
azimuth basically
exactly
um
right so
let me see just to understand this for a
second so
the term horizon
at a given geolocation
look i mean this is a corner case let's
not worry too much about this case we've
got plenty to worry about dealing with
the earth first of all so horizon means
horizon coordinate system
yeah on the earth
for now
but but you're saying the terrestrial
the the itrs system if you gave it a
geolocation on mars what's it going to
do
the
i-t-r-s this one
your terrestrial reference system what's
it going to do if you give it a geo
location on mars
well that one is for the earth so we
need to create some sort of i mean yes i
haven't added it here but we should have
one called for example planet centric
and then we can specify which planet we
need
we could generalize also itrs but itis
is very very precisely defined
with the properties of the earth
i understand that
but horizon look to my mind horizon
what's the difference in horizon and
these itrs things and so on
so all these other ones are centered at
the center of the earth
oh i see so that's the surface
exactly horizon is the only one that is
at the surface
and therefore it's the only one that
worries about the atmosphere algae
location etc
i think it's not got the right name here
does it have other names in astronomy
um
yeah my head horizon coordinate system
is what i've always heard it called um
topographic that's one
but i mean the difference between all
these other ones is that it is
the the main difference so we have first
so there are like three sets here the
ones centered at the solar system by
center the one centered at the at the
earth center the the geo center and then
the ones
the only one centered at a location why
don't we call it earth surface
earth's surface and then you've got to
give a geolocation as well in that case
if you're giving earth's surface
as
i mean okay so what happens if you're in
space
if you want to know from the iss for
example
um
actually jose didn't you say there's
already a kind of a a known reference
system for satellites it's one that you
haven't done yet i don't remember what
that one was called
was that that's indicated yes there is a
very technical thing here which is that
you see in the second set there is the
meme and the tete
so the these the
means mean equator mean equinox and the
other one is through equator two equinox
there is an intermediate one called teme
okay that is the one used by the
satellites
and it has some weird definition that i
don't yet have
um
but
so the point there is that these are
frames once you are in space you are not
interested on a horizontal plane you
directly use frames that are oriented
with the with earth access right to the
sequences you've got inertial frames
first you've got non-inertial but but
non-rotating frames next exactly next
you have the rotating frames and finally
in a different bucket
which i think should be separated off is
the geo is the earth surface one exactly
um
i mean maybe we should call it
geosurface
i think nobody will can be confused
about what that means it's the surface
of a
of
and then
you know if you say geosurface yeah it's
a coordinate system so if you are you
know a hunt 200 miles up from the
geosurface
it still referenced you know references
the geosurface
right
exactly
okay so i think we should call it
geosurface
as the coordinate system and then
geolocation
could in principle take a moon
geolocation and so on
and tough luck if you i mean jupiter
just is not a part of the game because
it doesn't have a surface
right
well it's not one that you'll get to and
in fact it has multiple coordinate
systems depending on what latitude
you're at so it's even more complicated
oh really yeah it rotates differentially
because it rotates faster than it does
right
um
okay
all right
uh
looks reasonable to me
um
now given a frame different coordinate
systems can be used now
i don't understand that statement
aren't the coordinates like lat long
coordinates how can they depend on the
projection
no no
lat long are always a spherical
coordinates they are always referred to
as central point
or at least a surface from which you
have
angles but sometimes you want to say x y
c i want cartesian coordinates
or cylindrical coordinates around the
axis of rotation
it's still the same frame
okay so
what are the units and in cartesian
coordinates actually simon on our live
stream is asking are the coordinates
just x y z and light years can we get
that like for a star for example how
would we get the astral position of
alpha centauri
in
xyz coordinates okay so let's do this as
an exercise
the nearest 10 stars i want them in
excel i mean we have this already that's
astronomical data i think the xyz
coordinates in light years relative to
us
right
so yeah we have a property called helio
coordinates which is
actually centered at the sun not the
berry center but um
it will give you the xyz and
a standard x cartesian coordinate system
for every body that we have in all the
astro domains
okay
but so so wait a minute and that is this
is that a rotating coordinate system
rotating somehow
with
you know
i don't understand how that works is
that relative to like the first point of
areas or whatever yeah it's i don't
remember which direction the x-axis is
pointed at it's probably the air point
at first point of aries but i don't
remember off the top of my head where
it's oriented
okay
right but so that's a direction that
itself moves so that's why you always
have to say of which date
so now that's precisely what has been
gained by using the icrs now you don't
have to say the date
right so we should be able to quote the
positions of santora and barnard star
and whatever else
in icrs coordinates exactly
and then those coordinates can be
cartesian or cylindrical or
spherical
okay
um
so the icrs is very close to an
equatorial system
so the xy plane is very close to the
xy plane of the earth in the year
2000 beginning of 2000
okay okay
so it's not that i don't know what how
is that oriented relative to the
galactic plane
one knows that because we can see where
the milky way is in the sky and it's
tipped without looking up i want to say
there's something like 26 degrees or
something like that i remember the exact
angle of the ecliptic with respect to
the galactic plane but they're it's a
measurable angle
so all these six
frames that are the in the first section
the initial ones those are all fixed
and there are
well-known matrices
3d rotations to go from one to the other
okay sorry the first two are essentially
the same one
so it's five
okay so
to convert between them we're just using
astroposition
as a wrapper with a different frame
outside and that will give us the
okay and so so just to understand like
when
how does this work
okay i see i see ics so the point is
just like with geo position if i say geo
position of a particular place
and
that's an entity
and then
i give in the second argument the stuff
about datums and so on it will compute
yeah okay so in this case what you're
saying is you'd say astral position of
beetlejuice comma
you know
uh teti or something
and that would give you the astral
position of that in that
exactly so i think this is a good moment
to look at some examples further now
okay can i ask this question what what
in the coordinates what units are the
coordinates in
yes so so this is this is some sort of
arbitrary decision at the moment so
angles i'm using radians
uh just to avoid continuous changes to
degrees but we could use degrees as well
um and then uh
times i'm using julian dates
and
distances i'm using meters
internally externally we can use
whatever we want or for type setting we
can use whatever we want
yeah
but they're going to be quantity objects
although they're going to be naked
numbers and meters internally they are
naked numbers like in the opposition
because we want to be able to use tons
of them's impactful
yeah
but
something i'm changing with respect to
geoposition is that this will always be
typeset
because the units in astro are a lot
less
homogeneous so for example right
ascension is always given in right
ascension hours minutes seconds of right
ascension while declinations are given
in degrees
right that already makes the whole thing
rather complicated from the readability
point of view
well okay so we've got a bunch of unit
disasters here
to me
you know we should solve the packing
problem which is an internal problem
independent of of declaring the units in
quantity objects i think it would be
really nice to get these units always to
come out with quantity objects
and i think that there will need to be
an option to astro position that
basically says what units you're going
to use because that way you can wrap you
know the the um uh you know the thing
for stars you can wrap it in something
which says give it to me in parsecs
i see
now one thing is how we store it
internally and another thing is what do
we get
with with properties so again like your
position your position you have
properties and you can get latitudes
longitudes etc yeah well i mean there's
the sort of outrageous fact that the you
know the
you know the universe is 10 to 26 meters
across
so that's smaller than 10 to 38 which is
the limit of what we can store
in
am i remembering correctly that well
that would be a 32 bit we can go bigger
than that right for
for um
how big can we go on floating point yeah
there's no problem in storing a distance
in meters anywhere in the universe
yeah no not at all
if we're using elementary lengths well
different story
we but we don't know what the elementary
length is so that's probably 100
magnitude smaller
so anyway never mind um we're not going
to count these things in elementary
lengths that's free that's for a future
design for a future
whatever um okay we could use
astronomical units too perhaps
yes and we could use many units but i
mean my point is that we don't know what
units we want to use right and therefore
we should be able to give an
astroposition we could i mean don't we
have a what is the thing target units
yeah target units right
is
oh
this is broken the um
uh
of course that could be mixed too
because astral position may contain both
angles and distances right i know i know
i know so we have to be more
sophisticated about this
i'm not sure if this is quite the right
option to use but i think we're going to
need an option to astroposition which
says
what units
i mean look really
we should get quantity objects out
because that's the only way we're not
going to get
ah the frustration is that as soon as
you're dealing with these in bulk you
don't really care about the quantity
objects they're all going to be the same
but i i think
internally i still think we should use
numbers in some arbitrarily chosen unit
and then the extraction is what requires
a unit and i agree with you there
so we could have astroposition bracket
bracket and then in another pair of
brackets we say
i don't know
coordinates comma meters or coordinates
comma
yeah i understand exactly
exactly
when you have the i mean for geo
position
right i mean if i say something like geo
position
of um
new york for example
and then i
say okay now what happens if i do a sub
value of this
so at here we still return a number but
we have the function latitude and that
returns a quantity
always in degrees
okay
this could this could be generalized and
we have latitude comma
i don't know we could also say latitude
quantity as the as the accessor here yep
we could do that indeed
and maybe that's the same thing we
should do with astroposition just have
something or other quantity
like right ascension quantity
and right ascension on its own is just a
number
right
sounds fine to me
um
we have accessors also to control the
order you can say latitude longitude or
longitudinal attitude sometimes people
want the other order things like that so
this is
ridiculous
yes
but okay but so so again let's take this
exercise i want the nearest stars xyz
coordinates parsecs
uh how do i do it
so i think we we would start by saying a
position of a star and um
astral position of series for example
and that gives you the um
oh my goodness
right
well i just said it was fragile
yes but that particular case i thought
it would work because it's in the in i
mean
today's build steven work for me is this
today's external or is this yesterday's
or
that's yesterdays
that might be improved it might be
improved today do you want to try it
yeah
let me try it locally first and i'll
report back
that should work for me i think it's the
first example or one of the first
examples further
sandra on a live stream is saying check
unit convert
quantity in target unit yeah
yeah i mean so that looks so long as we
can get quantities out of astral
position
and i kind of think what we should say
is astral position of just like latitude
here just gives a number latitude
quantity gives a quantity
it's still broken in today's build okay
and then if you want to convert it
you're using unit convert
um
i mean i think we've got to get some
experience using this thing and maybe
we'll want some other helper functions
just like we added latitude
as a
function for geoposition
that makes sense
yep
um
do we have latitude longitude is that is
that a function that we have
yes i think so yes yes we do
good i mean so that's the same
i mean maybe we want to wrap a function
for position we call it right ascension
declination
well it could be called that but it
could also be called
um
astro coordinates
okay and it could take a second argument
you feed it an astral position you give
it a second argument
that specifies
all kinds of random stuff about the
units you want and all this kind of
thing and whether you want horizon units
altitude azimuth or whether you want
right ascension declination
yes
and then astral coordinates would return
coordinates
not quantities by default
see what i'm saying
that would be inconsistent with what
latitude longitude does which returns
quantities right
yeah i would say by default it would
return some useful quantity
perhaps we can have a value that removes
so but i'm i'm saying that astro
coordinates a coordinate system
coordinates i claim and numbers
not quantity objects
i see so by that name you're you're
getting out of that box okay
whereas if you want the quantities you
do them as access or properties
that's at least a first thought
sandra is commenting that um
uh in
unit convert we have things like si base
units and imperial units so on yes but
sadly that doesn't for example tell you
about how to do angles
well maybe si says radiance i'm not sure
i guess it does
i guess it does and that's been a big
argument about why that angle is another
unit system there okay can we
um i think i understand go ahead no i
was going to say that it it this works
for me i'm sorry
it's broken in your build so i can show
you some examples if you join me too
show them yeah
so
so we can add like like quantities and
they will be converted i'm sorry that
telescope is not making it for me
that i can't come from yeah um
i just looked for some
astral related
icon in icon data it's this is the one i
found
yeah okay i i think what we should use
there
what do we have for geo position we
don't i see we don't have it for geo
position because geoposition gives the
naked coordinates
exactly yes so i mean there is such a
big change here right because this is
what people want they want the angle of
right ascension in in this
mixed notation while this is
degrees um and we discussed the other
day that the science should be wrong
yeah
um
okay listen with respect to the
telescope
that icon
but can we ask jeremy about that icon
and then i would suggest something which
is just some configuration of stars
[Music]
so what we do in in the opposition is
that we we kind of have a little map of
all the points
when we have many when there is only one
we show the numbers because they are
directly what people input
well here they are not
we should discuss that thing about
showing all the points i mean in other
words
in
i don't know what what um what
projection do we use to show the points
it is essentially a rectangular
okay directly lateral
okay
well i mean for astrophysician i
i have no idea i mean we could show that
position on the celestial sphere in
principle and that icon
i think that's a bit weird it it might
be very complicated because you need
context
and that's for such a small icon it's
hard to give that kind of context on
such a small amount well then i think
it's just some configuration of stars
some decorative configuration stars
okay so that is that so sirius there
okay exactly so this consults entity
value and gets the coordinates so can
you tell me where sirius is in the sky
for me right now so to speak
so for that
it will be like sun position
what is the thing that tells me where do
i look up in the sky to see sirius but
what is the altitude azimuth for sirius
um
presumably you'd have to say you know
you get the astral position first then
you have to convert it right jose
yes now the
this part i don't know that might be
broken exactly so but the change would
be something like take that value and
now convert it into the the horizon
frame
at your geolocation okay so you know
what i'm going to make a suggestion
maybe we should have a function called
sky position as well
that's similar to sun position
but sky position just tells you just
does this
just takes an object
and just tells you where is it in the
sky because that's you know since we are
currently on the surface of the earth
most of the time
uh i've spent my whole life on the
surface of the earth more or less
maximum
but yeah
i've ever been away from it it's 50 000
feet roughly once yes anyway never mind
um the uh but but what i'm saying is if
you want to find the i want to just know
the position of sirius in the sky
this this is a specification of the
position of series in the sky it's just
that it may not be with respect to the
three axis that you want astronomers are
more likely to use right ascension
declination as the sky position uh
whereas a manager observator amateur
astronomer might be more interested in
how high is it above my horizon things
like that so it kind of depends on who
your audience is
okay but if we had a sky position
function it is dealing with geolocation
to here it's dealing with horizon
wait a minute the bcrs frame
yes which is the same one as icrs as i
said so i don't even understand why that
right ascension declination
that's in that frame that's with respect
to the barry center of the solar system
yes
which is i think it's weird which i
think is weird i i was going to suggest
that something we should have as the
default is we should default we're going
to default to right ascension and
declination it should be at least
centered on maybe your geo position
dollar geoposition or something like
that
because
but you see the problem is that
this is something inertial so if we
refer to something that is on the earth
that's going to be changing
so
when you consult a catalog they give you
numbers that do not change and then if
you want to change to something else
i've got a suggestion
i've got a suggestion
that i think it's super confusing
to give
to write that as right ascension
declaration and that
somehow we've got to indicate that that
is a frame
look if we said frame bcrs paren
uh
you know
solar system barry center or some such
other thing at least you know that's not
look up in the sky
or something i mean in other words
to indicate in that thing
the b means solar system body center i
know so that's silly but but okay but
look the basic point is
those coordinates are pretty damn
meaningless to people yeah they're
they're technically nice and convenient
to use for computation but from a user
experience point of view it's going to
be very confusing because i saw right
ascension declination i know and you
think a second time right
so i i think that this astro position
arguably what we should do here is just
indicate that those are the coordinates
don't label them just say bcrs frame and
then give those things possibly even in
something like radians or something
because it doesn't matter because
they're just basically it's like a it's
like encryption keys they're essentially
just a hash code for this is the
position of sirius
jose do they actually call the
coordinates in the vcrs right ascension
and declination is that do they still
use the same terminology yes because
they are equatorial coordinates i mean
the pcrs is almost what you think of
equatorial coordinates it's just that
when you say equatorial coordinates you
have to
be very precise because the earth is
moving it's it's processing so the
equatorial coordinates that we project
from the earth onto the sky
change
so this is just a very very precise
specification of what you mean by that
okay but here's my suggestion okay
my suggestion is that we have a total of
three functions astro position astro
coordinates and sky position
okay and sky position
is something that gives you
stuff related to things on the earth
by default you might be able to get that
by it from astro position by giving
explicit you know geosurface
uh you know geosurface the the plan the
planet is earth the you know blah blah
blah blah blah all those kinds of things
which skype position only apply to earth
or would it also apply to things say if
you're on mars well
with yeah we can give some geo model
thing that we can give something
that um the point is it always depends
on your geo position so wherever you're
at right
hank
on our livestream saying current sky
position yeah we've kind of crossed that
bridge with sun position
and now which don't say current now they
just say
you know they're just it's sort of known
that it changes
um
but of course
sky position is only going to change if
it's altitude azimuth if it's right
ascension declaration it doesn't change
unless it's a planet
good point or an asteroid or anything
else that orbits in the solar system
yeah
in fact i got confused when i tried
creating an example using mars and i
tried to reproduce uh retrograde motion
and when i first did it in this
coordinate system i didn't see it
because the sun is at the center you're
at the very center and there's no
retrograde motion from there you only
see retrograde from earth and so i
realized i had to switch to uh
the g2000 or whatever
by the way presumably we will be able to
you know
satellites will be able to give the
astral position of the iss right
um yes yes
again
they will be naturally expressed on on
frames that are centered at the center
of the earth
yeah but we should be able to convert it
to bcrs if we wanted to
yes i mean it would be up now a very
long
vector from the center of the solar
system but but yes tough luck yeah yeah
they can of course but by the way why
are we using bcrs as the default not
icrs we say icrs is the coming up and
coming coordinate system
the truth is that i have been
doubting that a lot and i'm i still so
because people refer to both
equally
and meaning the
the same thing they use more frequently
icrs
but the truth is that bcrs is the
properly defined thing as i said icls is
the asymptotic version of bcrs the thing
that defines the orientation
icis doesn't say anything about
coordinates near this the sun
while vcrs does
okay
okay all right fine
but then
okay so look what i'm advocating and
we're going to need another meeting
because we're running out of time here
and um
um we should get another meeting next
couple of days on this we're getting
close but i let's think about the sky
position and astro coordinates as our
other
ways of accessing this information
okay
and um
and then what is this astro observe
thing remind me of that again
yes so the the question here is the
general problem of
observing one object from another taking
into account where it was when the light
was emitted
right so internally this it will be
controlled by this parameter of
of uh
of astral position and essentially it
means
rather than giving me the position where
it is right now in the hypersurfaces of
pcrs
give me the position where it was when
the light was submitted that i'm
receiving right now
yeah
and so so it's a function that
automatically will always give you this
[ __ ]
coordinate yeah
okay hold on
but it's it's just syntactic sugar
yeah but i mean it's for a pretty
obscure thing
not so much because if you want to point
your telescope what you are interested
is actually in that other
corner yeah right right right a space
like hyper services doesn't help you
exactly yeah
that's just for computation it's a
clearer thing to work with
but it's not a real thing you observe
by the way
when you i mean you're accounting for
the motion of planets
but you're not accounting for the
peculiar motion of stars right
that's proper motion yes sorry yes yes
so
so there is an extension that they
haven't written here which is that there
isn't a seven parameter input
which which will say t alpha delta r and
then the velocities on alpha delta and r
and that's that's something that's what
catalogues of stars give and
with that object as soon as you do a
computation it will just remove the
velocities
and give you the well very very new
catalogs of stars have that like gaia
which was its whole purpose was to
measure the proper motions of stars by
the way why don't we package those into
a
vector i mean rather than having them as
seven parameters why don't we say
in that case if you're going to give it
you can give t comma list alpha delta r
comma
list alpha prime delta prime r prime
it will again it's packing what words me
because if you have a large collection
of things
we
really want it to be packed
but that's exactly why we're building
this um
uh data container business
yes that's that's
pack and unpack more complicated things
um
but yes in this first
version this is not yet
documenting the proper motion
so
so proper motion is the motion of the
thing you are observing and then
aberration is the consequences
of the motion of the observer
right because if if the observer is
moving then the light rays are tilted
yep
and so it's very standard to do all
these computations in a way in which you
can
include or not include effects let me
make a comment here i mean
we don't have built into the system a
bunch of obvious relativistic things
maybe we should
yeah because like i mean the formula for
aberration is not complicated but i mean
the some of these things by now since
we're we're using relativistic effects
here we should be able to factor them
out
and for example we should be able to
take
a
what is the right answer we should be
able to take
a four vector
point in space time
and i mean it's a frames thing right we
should be able to say
in this inertial frame
specified in this way with this gamma et
cetera et cetera et cetera what is the i
i mean one doesn't usually think about
it this way in a sense what's the
projection of that
uh four vector into that frame
yes
i think you're right in the same way
that we have things like polymetrics we
could have learned matrices
yes
yeah we should we should and that they
will have some unit thing
with them you know we can have by
default they can have a gamma that's
dimensionless and otherwise they can
have something which is dimensional with
respect to the speed of light
um
yep okay
uh
okay but i think this observer thing is
right is where is it now
where is it for your sense of now
yeah exactly
okay
i mean to me that's more a sky position
story
you know the case of
that to me
the sky position would by default use
the [ __ ] coordinates
and that's probably the case you want i
mean the case the extremely obscure case
of i've got a satellite a spacecraft
going to wherever you know the
spacecraft going to mars
is decided it's going to have a little
convo with the spacecraft going to venus
that's a very obscure case
right i mean i think that because that's
the case for an observing
one thing from another neither of them
being earth
i i claim we should put this
functionality in the sky position
okay
so
yes i see what what you are saying to me
it will still be a particular case of
the general astroposition but it will be
of course of course particularly useful
case yeah yeah right that's what i'm
saying because i think the other case
for the general astro position is
something that one can do with these
light times and things like this
now the name i'm not fully sure because
when when one refers to the sky
typically you are saying i don't know
the distance so i'm projecting things to
infinity well astroposition wants to
know
the distance
and i think this is an independent
problem
fine but i think that
well i'm saying
look it's the same thing as geoposition
geoposition usually doesn't care about
the altitude but you can put it in if
you want to
i think that's okay and i think
um let me just ask this question it
seems to me we're going to need an astro
graphics
certainly and we and we might need a sky
graphics as well which might be
different
[Music]
not really
let me look for something i can show you
we have early versions of sky graphics
working
yes
um are you going to show again i need to
go in a second here
uh sorry um i can i can share now
sorry
okay
yes so this is the the futuristic
graphics that we were planning and it's
it it's it's right now model inside
geographics it's just that we have a sky
the model and it will be able to do
projections and show maps like this
or we we can zoom into a polar area
etcetera i mean
show me that first one again i'm sorry
yes that's lovely
what is that is that the milky way
that's a milky way and this is
yeah this is equatorial coordinates
and you see here for example orion you
see the the the belt of orion
so how do i see the milky way as
straight if i use galactic coordinates
it better be straight
exactly exactly and for example just
just by telling the system that you want
at the center a star that is deciduous
it will already could be that
but when i look up in the sky okay let's
be very naive here i'm
you know i see the milky way as a
straight line
because i'm seeing
okay so
okay let's just to pull together a few
things we hopefully will soon have
spherical image
right spherical image
would be a correct sky image
am i making sense whereas image image is
a projected sky image
yes
but spherical image could be the actual
correct sky image
right it would be like like a 3d version
so they can i can
rotate with the mouse or something
yes
yes but in particular it means that
in vr for example you can just have it
be right okay
but now normally the projection that is
the effective projection that is the
projection onto my eye
is what
that's basically this whatever this is
what is this is this orthographic
projection
i think this is number number
which is the one that can describe the
whole sky so this point over here is the
same point
okay but i'm just asking naive question
when i look up at the sky right i am
effectively doing my retina is
two-dimensional
but
i am taking the three-dimensional
thing painted on the sky and i'm mapping
it to my two-dimensional retina what is
the effect of projections like using
i think from the point of view of your
projection that's a stereographic
projection it's like like making
everything going through a point
on the surface of the sphere
okay but so is this is there a
stereographic projection for
geoprojection there isn't is there is it
that is of course yeah
there is okay
yes it's one of the conformal
projections yes
but so for the earth
because
looking at the earth from space
what projection are you using when you
look at the earth from space
that's the same type of problems the one
i'm describing here
right there graphic projection or
something different
so those are so those projections that
simulate what the eye does are called
the
perspective projections
and so you have
you have you can specify parameters of a
camera
okay with the focal length and so on
yes and the aperture and things like
that
and um and then in in a sense
it's it's like imagine that that you
have the the
the circle of the sphere
if you look at it from very very far
away that's orthographic as you get
closer
that's the general perspective
projection and then when you are looking
at the sphere from the surface
that's stereographic and when you are
looking at the sphere from the center
that's
the mnemonic projection
so there is a line
mnemonic
okay so so i mean we can do this with
geographics
so i can say world
and i can say here geo
projection this would be a stereographic
so the stellography projection is
looking at a sphere from a point of the
sphere and
okay
your current lines this this always
helps
okay yep right
and then there is the mnemonic
projection which will be looking at it
from the center and then orthographic is
like the extreme case of being very very
far away
so graphic
and then you can only see half of the
sphere okay now what would show me the
mnemonic
this is a rather complicated one
is that the one that's relevant for the
for the sky
because you're seeing from the inside
the sky from the inside
well if you want this would be the what
you call this um
spherical image if we were able to drag
this one
if it would yes
of some kind exactly our eye can only
see like a center part of the earth so
we don't see this this enormous
distortion that we see on the border
i have to go to another meeting but
let's um
uh
can you think about these things we've
talked about for the oh and
and this astrographics thing looks
lovely
wonderful
really cool
is that is that very close now
i think
we need to discuss all the various
options and objects that we can support
inside but but the key ideas are there
already
and it will take projections and it will
take the various frames
so that would you specify from where you
are looking at etc wow
very very cool wow
long long journey to get here but this
is really cool
all right um i should run for people who
are watching these live streams we are
about to start another live stream about
a completely different topic looking at
the toolbar
so okay
great work see you later